so here is a here is a thought worth
reflecting on we were all very impacted
when Elon Musk demonstrated his new
rockets that could literally land itself
perfectly upon completion of its mission
and why was that so compelling aside
from the fact that it completely upended
what we thought was possible with
rockets but the idea of taking off for
the great unknown the amount of
explosive ferocity and the compressed
power required to blast a rocket off
into space is something that almost
invites the idea that all must be left
behind you have to shed your skin you
have to die who you were you have to
risk it all there's a annihilation that
accompanies the blasting off of a rocket
and of course it sheds the pieces into
the sea it's like it leaves kind of
destruction in its wake
meanwhile what Elon Musk has
accomplished with his new rocket that
against all of our intuition after
blasting off into orbit returns to earth
and elegantly lands itself it almost
looks like a video on rewind
like it feels like a mind trick or like
an illusion but in fact what it shows is
that to accompany the surrender in the
ecstasy of blasting off into the unknown
here must also be the intention and the
discipline to make the return right from
the perspective of kind of archetypal
mythology Joseph Campbell talks about
answering the call to adventure by
taking the journey risk being at all but
deployed the discipline and the training
right so that the training kicks into
gear right to go through to go through
the idea that's aside from human being
needing to die and leave everything they
may be in order to discover new
frontiers and transcend their
limitations that there is an equally
important capacity and responsibility to
make the return right not be destroyed
in the process we need not be martyred
for the cause of extending our reach and
extending our boundaries after the
ecstasy the laundry not just the trash
in any way
the idea of the rocket the blasts off
then returns elegantly is akin to what
we must do with a circular economy with
the environment which sustainability
that we can expand the boundaries of
what we are we can go forth and
transcend and discover all the wonderful
justifications given by people who want
to pierce the beyond but it doesn't mean
we have to destroy what came before in
the process that in fact we don't have
to play the finite game to win or lose
or that for every winner there's a loser
for every victory there have to be
losses oh no we can play the infinite
game instead which the purpose of the
game is to keep the game going it is a
sustainable game
so anyway that was the reflection that I
just had in a response to thinking about
how astonishing and amazing and
counterintuitive this achievement of a
rocket that Elon Musk has created it
takes off and represents everything that
is noble and amazing about humankind but
then with it is sobering in a
responsible capacity to take all of that
blast off of me like bring it right back
after the mission deal and with that we
have something to give
that uh yeah that rocket taking off for
my benefit
we must do